Hello, welcome to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A.
My name is Angela Lomy. I'm glad that
you've tuned in. You are going to be
blessed. Get your Bibles, get your pens,
get your iPad or whatever you use your
get the word of God on. Get that and
join us and look up those Bible texts as
we go through a journey in the Bible
together, you and me and the panelists.
Well, thank you so much for tuning in
and I'm going to introduce the panelists
right now. Let's start with Pastor Ryan
Johnson. Welcome, Pastor Johnson. Oh,
it's wonderful to be here. You know,
every time we study the word, we are not
only brought closer to God, but also
closer to each other. So, I'm looking
forward to this. Oh, amen. Absolutely.
All right. P Oh, I was going to say,
pastor, you're on your way. Preacher.
Yeah. He's He is a preacher of
righteousness. He gives wonderful
sermons at our church. Uh Ian Vanderald,
welcome. Thank you for having me. It's
always a pleasure to be surrounded by
people who just want to learn and grow
together. And I get to learn so much
from being on here. So it's it's really
enjoyable. Amen. Amen. And in front of
me is the love of my life, Pastor John
Lukang. Welcome, honey. Good to be here
with the love of my life. Good to have
you here. And thank you for your uh
questions. We always learn and you
always challenge us. Amen. Amen. Pastor
Ryan Johnson, would you please open with
prayer? Oh yes. Oh, Father in heaven, we
are here with open Bibles. And now,
Lord, we pray that you would open our
hearts and our minds. Let your spirit
descend upon us, Lord, here in the
studio. And everyone watching, Lord, or
listening, open us, Lord, to what you
have for us and save us in your kingdom.
In thy name we pray. Amen. Amen. Thank
you. Now, you may be wondering, how
could I send my question in? Okay, well,
you can text us by texting us at
6182283975 or if you want to send an
email, you can email us at
bibleqa3abn.tv. Maybe you're an
Instagram person, you can Instagram us
by going to
3ABN official. Okay. All right. Let's
start with our first question. It's
going to be you, honey. John, Pastor
John. Here we go. I was following a
Bible reading on YouTube and they said
that pork and shrimp are not unclean to
us because we are no longer under the
curse. It says Jesus bore these curses
on the cross and under the new covenant.
We are free from the Mosaic law. Can you
explain Mark 7 verse
15-23? This is from Megan in Virginia.
Thank you, Megan. Let's begin by going
to the passage. The question had a lot
of components in there. Some of them in
conflict and I'll go ahead and try by
God's word to clarify it. Mark chapter 7
verse1 15. There is nothing that enters
a man from outside which can defile him,
but the things which come from out of
him. Those are the things that defile a
man. Verse 16. If anyone has ears to
hear, let him hear. When he had entered
a house away from the crowd, his
disciples asked him concerning the
parable. Now listen to what Jesus said.
So he said to them, "Are you thus
without understanding also?" And this is
the key. Do you not perceive that
whatever enters a man from outside
cannot defile him because it does not
enter his heart but his stomach and is
eliminated thus purifying all foods. And
here's the key. And he said, "What comes
out of a man that defiles a man. For
from within out of the heart of men
proceed look at the things that corrupt
us. evil thoughts, adulteries,
fornications, murders, thefts,
covetousness, wickedness, deceit,
lwdness, and evil eye, blasphemy, pride,
foolishness. All these evil things come
from within and defile a man. The focus
of the passage was not food, but the
condition of the human heart. You know,
when you go back to the book of Genesis,
before sin entered the world, the Lord
created two classes of animals. those
that were clean and those that were
unclean. You find this in Genesis as it
relates to just before the flood. The
Lord said in Genesis 7:2, "You shall
take with you seven each of every clean
animal, a male and this female, two each
of animals that are unclean, a male and
a female." Now you might ask question
this the question for what and unclean
for what? Now the reason is clearly
clean for food and unclean for food
because after the flood there would be
no more vegetation for quite a while and
God was providing for them that which
they would need for sustenance, physical
sustenance. And so people read this
passage and think okay now Jesus
cleansed all food. Well I ask you a
question today. Would you just eat
anything because it moves on the ground?
And I guarantee you would say no. What
we put in our bodies medically speaking
not even scripturally can affect us
tremendously. many diseases that affect
us today. So the Lord was not cleansing
uh unclean things. He was not saying now
eat an animal that eats a dead animal.
He was not saying that at all. He was
not saying eat scavengers that eat dead
things. He was not saying that at all.
What he was in essence saying is the
condition of the heart is the focus of
the passage. Matthew 23 27 look at what
the Bible says.
Woe to you scribes and Pharisees and
notice hypocrites, for you are like
whitewashed tombs, which indeed appear
beautiful outwardly, but inside are full
of dead men's bones and all uncleanness.
That's the key. What was unclean was the
heart of those claiming to be religious.
They ate good, but they were corrupt
spiritually. That's why David's prayer
in Psalm 51:10 was, "Create in me a
clean heart, oh God, and renew a right
spirit within me." So when you look at
the Bible and you read in Deuteronomy uh
chapter 11, Deuteronomy 15 and Leviticus
chapter 11, you find the list of clean
and unclean foods. And today, people
that are not even Christians recognize
that they are filthy animals. You can
walk around the neighborhood and you
could see a buzzard eating a a a
squirrel that just got run over. You're
not going to say to the buzzard, "Get
out of the way. I want that squirrel for
dinner." Because you know in your heart
that's unclean. In the very same way,
your body is God's temple. He does not
want you to defile it. But the focus of
this was not the condition of the
unclean and clean food. The focus of
this was the clean heart and the unclean
heart. That's what really defiles us.
That's right. And it wasn't just for
Jews, was it? No, it was not at all for
Jews. It was for anybody that we was
created. We have the same uh digestive
system. Exactly. Thank you so much for
that. All right. Let's go to Ian
Vanderval. Can you explain Philippians 2
verse 5-7? This is someone in Oregon.
All right. Well, thank you to the person
in Oregon who sent this in. So, let's
read Philippians 2:es 5-7. Let this mind
be in you which was also in Christ
Jesus, who being in the form of God, did
not consider it robbery to be equal with
God, but made himself of no reputation,
taking the form of a bondervant and
coming in the likeness of men. Now, I
want to give you a little bit of a
backstory to this. Now, Paul had a
special connection with the people of
Philippi, because while he was there, he
actually received um funds from them,
some necessities is what the Bible calls
it. You can read about it in Philippians
chapter 4. And he didn't do it or they
didn't do it just once, but they
actually helped him on a couple of
occasions. You can see in verse 16 of
chapter 4 of Philippians when no other
church was going to help him, he says,
"You sent aid once and again for my
necessities." So Paul had a special
connection with these people. And what
what he received was word that division
was now taking place within the people
of Philippi. You can read about that in
uh Philippians chapter 1 where it says
that you stand fast in one spirit with
one mind striving together for the faith
of the gospel. So he's reaching out to
them and appealing to them. And in verse
29 of chapter 1 he even says for you
have taken or you have been granted on
behalf of Christ not only to believe in
him but also to suffer for his sake. And
even again in Philippians chapter 4,
this is uh he reveals more division that
was taking place between two women. Uh
the names were Yuodia and Cintichi. Now
um Jesus now we know he even Jesus says
that a house divided cannot stand. So
Paul is making an appeal to the people
of Philippi. So let's go back to the
verse in the verse in question which is
uh Philippians chapter 2 and we're going
to read 5-7. I'm going to break this up
in pieces for you. All right. So we're
going to start here in verse 5 and it
says, "Let this mind be in you which was
also in Christ Jesus." Now what does
that mean? Paul actually explained all
of this in the previous verses 1-4 where
he says, "Fulfill my joy by being
like-minded, having the same love, being
of one accord and being of one mind."
And then we're going to pick up now in
verse six where it says, "Who being in
the form of God did not consider it
robbery to be equal with God." Now,
we're told in John 14:9, "He who has
seen me has seen the father." And we
know that Jesus was side by side with
his father and that they are equals.
John 1 verse one says, "In the beginning
was the word and the word was God and
the word was with God." So also now
moving on into verse 7, but made himself
of no reputation, taking the form of a
bondervant and coming in the likeness of
men. Now this is so key. Christ gave up
everything he had in heaven. He came as
a servant to seek and to save that which
is lost. Think about that for a second.
The master artist who painted the stars
in the sky, who spoke the worlds into
existence, and who carefully crafted
both you and I is the same God who left
all of that for you and me. So keep that
in mind. What uh what Paul is trying to
stress here is for us to be united to
have that same unselfishness just as
Christ did where he left everything for
us. Amen. Wow. Beautiful. Amen. That's
that's the God I choose to serve. All of
us here choose to serve that God. A
loving God. Thank you, Ian, for that.
All right, Pastor Johnson,
here's your question. Okay, this is from
Eleanor. It says,"I have noticed that I
have trouble sleeping on Saturday
nights. I believe this is due to not
engaging in physical activity on
Sabbath. Do you have any suggestions on
how I can overcome this unfortunate
situation and still manage to keep the
Sabbath day holy?" This is from Eleanor.
Sister Eleanor, this is an excellent
question and thank you for giving us an
opportunity to talk about this. So, it
sounds as though you are a Sabbathke
keeper. You keep the seventh day holy as
the commandments say that we should do
and you are resting on the Sabbath. Now,
I have a medical background. So, before
we get into the scripture, just here are
a couple things we want to make sure
you're okay. Are you sure that it is
only Saturday night when you are having
trouble resting? Go ahead and talk to
your doctor if you need to. But here are
some things that can maybe keep us up.
If you're like me, you have potluck on
Sabbath and then on Saturday night we're
hanging out with friends. So sometimes
we eat a little bit more on Sabbath than
we normally do. So you could be having
some discomfort at night because of
that. And here's an interesting one. And
I as a pastor would go to church on
Sabbath and that's when all of the the
stuff that's going on would come to you.
Am I telling the truth, Pastor Lone
King? And sometimes at night, you know,
if you're an officer, you're thinking
about all the things that can keep you
up. I find that reading the word of God,
reading some spirit of prophecy, singing
a song can help clear the mind. But if
it is that you are having difficulty
resting on Sabbath evening because, as
you've said, you haven't really done any
activity on Sabbath in an effort to keep
the Sabbath day holy. This is a very
good thing to talk about. So, let's go
to scripture. We're going to go to Luke
chapter 6, and I want to read verse one.
But before I do, I'm going to read verse
5. Listen to what Jesus says. That the
Son of Man is Lord also of the Sabbath.
So Jesus is Lord of the Sabbath. Well,
if he is Lord of the Sabbath, let's see
what he has to say. And now we're going
to go to verse one. And it came to pass,
this is Luke 6, on the second Sabbath
after the first, that he went through
the corn fields. He went, he was
walking, and his disciples plucked the
ears of corn, and did eat, rubbing them
in their hands. And certain of the
Pharisees said unto them, "Why do ye
that which is not lawful to do on the
Sabbath days?" And remember, we just
established Christ is Lord of the
Sabbath, and there on the Sabbath, the
Lord of the Sabbath is walking. You can
walk on the Sabbath. And if you find
just walking idally to be a little less
holy on the Sabbath than you want, here
are some things you can do. You can
visit somebody on the Sabbath, walk to
their house, you can pass out
literature. We used to do that. Remember
in gathering? You can walk. You can get
on your feet in the service of the Lord.
But in Job chapter 12, let me see if we
have time to go here. I really like
this. Look at what Job says. He says,
"But ask, ask the beasts, and they shall
teach thee, and the fowl of the air, and
they shall tell thee." Verse nine, "Who
knoweth not in all these that the hand
of the Lord hath wrought this?" You can
find God by observing his handiwork. And
I've discovered that walking with my
kids through nature gets us closer to
God gives us exercise, and we are
keeping the Sabbath. So maybe try those
things out, Sister Eleanor. Amen. And I
like that. Very good. And when you live
in the city, sometimes it's a little
difficult. All these stores. When we
used to live in Brooklyn, we had to take
the bus to go to church. And sometimes
it was a challenge cuz your mind would
kind of drift. But that's why I love
living in the country. You're out in
nature. Thank you. Praise the Lord.
Okay, Pastor Lom Kang. Yes. This is a
quick easy one. Oh, I don't know if it's
easy. Here goes. This is from Darl. It
says, "If Satan knows he will be
defeated in the end, why does he not
repent?"
Thank you for that question. Now, that's
a question that I've heard many years
ago. We had a pastor in uh conference in
California that once preached a sermon
and said, "I think the devil can still
be saved if he repents." Well, he
cannot. That's virtually and spiritually
impossible because of the cross and the
empty tomb. Revelation 12:12 talks about
what happened after the cross. Now
before the cross, Satan had limited
access to heaven. He was able to go back
and forth to and fro. You find that in
the book of Job. There was a day that
the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord. And the
devil came also. And the question was
where did you come from? And he says
from going back and forth and to and fro
in the earth. But something happened at
the cross. Let me make it very clear.
When he sinned, he wanted to replace
God. Isaiah 14:14, he said, "I will be
like the most high." The Lord said, "No,
you will not. You'll be cast to the
earth." And so, he cast him out. That is
the casting out of heaven. But the
casting down happened at the cross,
which means he was permanently defeated.
Look at Revelation 12:12. And notice
what the Bible says after that point.
Therefore, rejoice, O heavens, and you
who dwell in them. That's all the
unfallen worlds. Woe to the inhabitants
of the earth and the sea for the devil
has come down to you having great wrath
because he knows he has a short time.
Now there are those like a rock group
many years ago called the Rolling
Stones. They put out an album called
Sympathy for the Devil. There are those
who are sympathizing with him because
their life is in harmony with his
character and they believe that somehow
he was unfairly treated by God. But the
Bible says after the cross when Jesus
says all power is given me in heaven and
in earth and he defeated the enemy by
coming forth from the grave. The devil
said that's it. My time is short. And
what did Jesus do? Hebrews 2:14 it says
in as much then as the children have
partaken of flesh and blood he himself
that is Jesus likewise shared in the
same that through death and here's the
key. he might destroy him who had the
power of death that is the devil. So by
the cross it was not just the
crucifixion but it was his burial. It
was not just the burial but when he came
forth he gained complete victory over
the penalty of sin, the power of sin and
soon we will all experience victory over
the presence of sin. So the devil knows
he doesn't have any more chances. Why?
Because the wages of sin is death. Those
wages that cause us to sin were paid by
Jesus. But the cause of sin will be bore
by him. And what is that? The wages of
sin is death. He knows his time is
short. And that's what the Bible says in
Revelation chapter 20. This is the
second death. The devil and the false
prophets will experience the second
death. Friends, the devil has no chance
of being saved. That's too late. It's
gone.
His time's up, isn't it? He knows it. He
knows he has a short time. Yeah. And
he's trying to take as many with him as
possible. Don't go on this on the
devil's team. I would say don't I always
say don't bust into his party. Hell is
prepared for the devil and his angels,
not for anybody that God created. Amen.
Thank you for that, honey. All right,
Ian. In 1st Samuel
31:4 says that Saul took a sword and
fell on it.
2 Samuel 1 verse 10 says, "So I stood
over him and killed him." This is
confusing. Did Saul kill himself or did
the Amalachite kill him? This is from
Zadei.
All right. Well, Zadeie, thank you so
much for your question. And you're
right. It it uh at first look it could
be uh confusing, but we're going to go
through that and hopefully make it very
clear for you. So, let's uh read 1st
Samuel 31, and I'm going to read verses
4 and 5 where it says, "Then Saul said
to his armor bearer, "Draw your sword
and thrust me through with it, lest
these uncircumcised men come and thrust
thrust me through and abuse me. But his
armor bearer would not, for he was
greatly afraid." Therefore, Saul took a
sword and fell on it. And when his armor
bearer saw that Saul was dead, he also
fell on his sword and died with him. Now
here we clearly see as you mentioned
that Saul had taken his own life and
then the armor bearer confirming that
Saul was dead then took his own life as
well. Now let's jump to 2 Samuel chapter
1 and we're going to read several verses
here because I want to make sure you
have the entire context. We're going to
read verses 1-10. Now it came to pass
after the death of Saul when David had
returned from the slaughter of the
Amalachites and David had stayed two
days in Ziglag. On the third day,
behold, it happened that a man came from
Saul's camp with his clothes torn and
dust on his head. So it was when he came
to David that he fell on the ground and
prostrated himself. And David said to
him, "Where have you come from?" So he
said to him, "I have escaped from the
camp of Israel." Then David said to him,
"How did the matter go? Please tell me."
And he answered, "The people have fled
from the battle. Many or excuse me, many
of the people are fallen and dead." and
Saul and Jonathan his son are dead also.
So David said to the young man who told
him, "How do you know that Saul and
Jonathan his son are dead?" Then the
young man who told him and said, and
this is what's really key, as I happened
by chance to be on Mount Gilboa, there
was Saul leaning on his spear, and
indeed the chariots of horsemen followed
hard after him. Now when he had looked
behind him, he saw me, and he called to
me, and and I answered him, "Here am I."
And he said to me, "Who are you?" So I
answered him, "I am an Amalachite." And
he said to me again, "Please stand over
me and kill me, for anguish has come
upon me, but my life still remains in
me." So I stood over him and killed him
because I was sure that he could not
live after he had fallen. And I had took
the crown that was on his head and the
bracelet that was on his arm and have
brought them here to my Lord. Now, when
you look at the full context of
everything that we read, and I know it
was a lot, if you look back at verse 6,
the Amalachite tells David that he just
happened by chance to be on Mount
Gilboa. And therefore, he just happened
by chance to be in the middle of this
battle and find Saul. So, the truth is,
and the real chance is is that this
Amalachite probably did come upon Saul,
but Saul was already dead. And this
Amalachite thinking and knowing that
David would be the next to succeed, was
looking for some kind of reward. and
which is the reason why he brings the
the uh the crown as well as the
bracelet. So in summary, Saul did commit
suicide. He did kill himself and the
Amalachite was just falsely claiming
what he would in order to receive a
reward. Wow. Very good. Wow. Well said.
Thank you. Amen. Opportunist. Yeah.
Opportunist. The Amalachites. Yeah.
Okay. Pastor Johnson, here's your
question. Can you
explain Matthew
4:1? It says that the spirit led Jesus
into the wilderness to be tempted by the
devil. Does the Holy Spirit lead us into
temptation? This is from Jenny in
Washington. Oh, Jenny, that's a
excellent question because this right
here sheds light on our understanding of
God and who he is. Well, let's go to
Matthew chapter 4. But what I'd like to
do is a bit of a leadup into it, shall
we? So, I'm going to go into Matthew 3,
and I'm going to start in verse 13. Then
cometh Jesus from Galilee to Jordan unto
John to be baptized of John. 14 But John
forbad him, saying, I have need to be
baptized of thee, and comest thou to me?
And Jesus in verse 15 answering said
unto him suffer it to be so now for thus
it becometh us to fulfill who fulfill
all righteousness. Jesus was on a
mission and then he suffered him. Now
look at this verse 16. And Jesus when he
was baptized went up straightway out of
the water. And lo, the heavens were
opened unto him. And he saw the spirit
of God descending like a dove. Oh mercy
and lighting upon him and low a voice
from heaven saying this is my beloved
son in whom I am well pleased. The
spirit descended upon Jesus. Jesus was
under the spirit. He even says in
certain places the spirit of the lord is
come upon me. So with that in mind we go
into chapter 4. Then was Jesus led up of
the spirit h into the wilderness to be
tempted of the devil. And there's the
crux of it. Does the spirit lead us to
be tempted? Clearly the spirit is there
and the scripture says this. So what I'd
like to do is I would like to state this
verse but conversely before we break it
down. What if it said, "Then Jesus went
into the wilderness, but the spirit
didn't tell him to go." Oh, that would
be something, would it not? So, praise
the Lord that Jesus was moving under the
direction of the spirit. That is one.
But when we look at this word tempted,
it's actually a Greek word pirato and it
means to be tried or to be tested. And
in that eastern culture, this was
expected. And you see this also the
prophets going back. There was this
period of being tested. But let us not
forget what Jesus went into the
wilderness to do was to fast and pray.
And that's what it says. But yet it says
to be tempted of the devil. So let's
look at this from another perspective.
We're going to go to Mark where Mark
gives his perspective of this. This is
Mark chapter 1 and I'm going to start
reading in verse 12. Same thing. It
says, "And immediately the spirit
driveth him, Jesus, into the
wilderness." And in the next verse, it
says,
"And he was there in the wilderness 40
days tempted of Satan." This is
different. It doesn't say the spirit
drove him into the wilderness to be
tempted. It says the spirit drove him
into the wilderness and he was tempted.
So we begin to see here that Jesus is
being led into the wilderness and the
tempter is there. So let's just
establish something. No, the spirit does
not lead us to temptation. Don't you
know the tempter is the enemy, but the
spirit does allow us to be tested.
Exactly. And when we have the spirit, we
will be victorious. Well, let's look a
little bit more. Why the wilderness?
What is in the wilderness? Jesus is
going aside to fast and pray in the
wilderness. And don't you often find
that when you go aside to get closer to
God, here comes the tempter. Anyhow,
Jesus is experiencing this. But but
Jesus is on a mission. Jesus is setting
an example for us. Jesus has come to
save us. And yes, it was the will of the
spirit, the will of God that he go to
set an example for us that by the power
of God, we can be victorious when the
tempter comes. That is the intent of the
spirit. Praise God. As you said, the
Bible says by the power of God. Thank
you for that, Pastor Johnson. Yes, we
can do how many things through Christ?
All things. All things through Christ.
Amen. Thank you. Now, maybe you've just
tuned in and you say, "Oh, how do I send
my question in?" Text us by texting at
6182283975. Or if you want to email us,
you can email us at
bibleqa3abn.tv. Or if you're an
Instagrammer, you can Instagram us. Go
on Instagram. Go to
3ABN official. So, those are the ways
you can send your question in. Send them
in. We want to hear from you and we will
be sure to go to the word of God. Amen.
Thank you. All right, let's go to Pastor
John. Here's your question. Why was such
a detrimental act done to Ananas and
Safh for lying to the Holy Spirit?
Please help me to understand why they
fell over and died. This is from David
in Florida. Well, thank you David.
That's a beautiful question. The context
of this, the New Testament church is
being established and the Lord wanted to
send a strong message. Now, we know uh
Romans 6:23, the wages of sin is death.
When you read the story there in the
book of Acts, I believe it's Acts
chapter 5, you find that there was an
agreement between Ananas and Safh. They
had sold a property that was theirs
before they sold it. They pledged to
give the proceeds to the church, which
when the Lord blessed that, he blessed
it pressed down, shaken together, and
running over. Ananas said, "Wait a
minute. I got I could get my Mercedes
now. I'm not giving all this money to
the church." And Safari said, "That coat
I saw at Macy's, I want to get that
coat." So they took the money they
pledged to give to the Lord. And and the
wise men Solomon said, "Suffer not thy
mouth to cause thy flesh to sin. It's
better not to vow than to vow and not to
pay. The Lord want to make it very clear
in the New Testament church that he was
not hand he was not going to tolerate
this kind of sin. This was premeditated.
They knew what they were planning to do.
And the Bible says in Ecclesiastes 8 and
vers 11, because the sentence against an
evil work is not executed speedily,
therefore the heart of the sons of men
is fully set in them to do evil. So they
said, you know, we could get away with
this. The Lord says, not in this church.
So God wanted an example to be set that
as the church is being established. It
was not hatred for Ananas and Safh, but
hatred for sin, God revealing his wrath
against sin. That was a prime example.
And Peter said, you know, you got to be
careful when the pastor asks certain
questions the way he does. Now, Ananas,
how much did you sell it for? When he
asked that question, he knows the answer
already. So he drops dead and the
deacons, can you imagine? He said, "Look
at the dirt on the deacons feet. They
just buried your husband." She comes in
about three hours later sporting her
outfit from Macy's. Now I'm not picking
on Macy's. Figured, "Oh, check me out,
church." And they said, "Why has you why
have you tempted the Lord? Why have you
tested God? You have not lied to man
alone, but you have lied to God. You've
lied to the Holy Spirit." And see, the
men that buried your husband, they're
going to bury you, too. And she dropped
down dead. Let me tell you something. I
can guarantee you that Sabbath when
offering was collected, everybody
returned a good tithe. Everybody gave an
honest offering. The church grew because
God gave an example. And that's why the
Bible says, what did they do? They
blasphemed the spirit of God. The g the
God that they served was appealing to
them and they turned off the voice of
the spirit. So there was no room for
forgiveness. Matthew 12 and:e 32, anyone
who speaks a word against the son of
man, it will be forgiven him. But
whoever speaks against the Holy Spirit
will not be forgiven him either in this
age or the age to come. They bore the
results of resisting the spirit of God.
Now, here's the key. When God's saying,
"Don't do it. Don't do it. Don't do it."
And you say, "I'm going to do it, and
I'm going to do it at church." That's
what Ananas and Safara had done. And
that may be your experience. Don't do
it. Amen. Amen. You did that sermon
years ago called Heart Attacks in Holy
Places. And when I was preaching that in
Pittsburgh, California, somebody had a
heart attack during the service. I'm not
kidding. Paramedics were taking them out
while I was preaching. Oh no. So, but
you did stop and pray. I still We
stopped and prayed, but it happened.
Heart attacks in holy places and they
had a heart attack in the middle of that
sermon. Have mercy. Terrible conviction.
Okay, let's move on. Okay, Ian, here's
your question. Can you give examples
from the Bible on how it handles wine
and whether it's okay to drink it? This
is from Tanji, I think. All right. Well,
again, thank you as always for your
question. And the Bible refers to two
different types of wine. There's fresh
grape juice and then there's the
alcoholic or fermented wine. Now, in the
Old Testament, they actually use two
different words to define between the
two. And I may pronounce these wrong, so
don't hold me to that. But uh one of
them being uh ti ro and that is the
fresh grape juice and the other being
yayen which is the uh the alcoholic
wine. Now in the New Testament there's
only one word that actually defines
between the wine and which is called
oos. So you're going to have to read
more into the context to be able to
determine which one it is speaking to.
Now the Bible though does make it very
clear of the difference between grape
juice and fermented wine as well as its
effects. You can read in Proverbs 20 and
verse one, "Wine is a mocker, strong
drink is raging, and whosoever is
deceived thereby is not wise." Now, the
Bible also uses a word that we don't
really use here in today's uh language,
but uses the word woe, which just means
grief or despair. And in Proverbs 23, uh
29-32 says, "Who has woe? Who has
sorrow? Who has contentions? Who has
complaints? Who has wounds without
cause? Who has redness of eyes? And
here's the answer. Those who linger long
at the wine. And then again in Habach
chapter 2 verse1 15 where it says, "Woe
to him who gives drink to his neighbor,
pressing him to to your bottle even to
make him drunk that you may look upon
his nakedness." Now we even see examples
in God's word of individuals who have
been impacted. And these are people who
are considered righteous. Now in in uh
Genesis chapter 9 verse 21 and 22 this
is about Noah who in the book of Hebrews
refers to Noah as being a righteous man
as well as in second Peter. Now in
Genesis 9 21-2 says then he drank of the
wine and was drunk and became uncovered
in his tent and Ham the father of Canaan
saw the nakedness of his father and told
his two brothers outside. Now you as you
read on you'll see that the outcome of
this that even Canaan was cursed because
of this. Now also in Genesis chapter 19
and verse 32, this is speaking of Lot
and I'll tell you a little bit more of
the context of what occurred but in
Genesis chapter 32 it says come let us
make our father drink wine and we will
lie with him that we may preserve the
lineage of our father. Now, the ones
that actually did this was this was
Lot's uh daughters who intentionally got
him drunk to continue his line. And out
of that line came the Ammonites as well
as the Moabites who became enemies with
Israel. Now, there are some who do
suggest that the miracle that took place
at the wedding that Jesus actually
turned that water into wine. Now, I want
you to to understand something here.
There are about six water pots. each one
of them carrying approximately 20 to 30
gallons. Now, do you really believe that
the God that our savior created anywhere
between 120 to an 180 gallons of
alcoholic wine? That is actually after I
did a little bit of research, that's
approximately about 17 to 18% of what
Americans consume in a year. So, in one
night, you're saying that that's what
Jesus created? I don't think so. Now we
also think that the effects of wine may
not be but maybe I can just have one
glass of wine. Even one glass of wine
can actually impair your cognitive and
brain function. And even according to
the National Cancer Institute even small
amounts of consumption can be a high
risk for certain cancers of drinking
wine. And on top of that, based on
recovery centers that experiencing
people that are dealing with alcoholism,
they say that there are major effects
even on the family such as damaging
family relationships and domestic abuse
and even uh physical and mental
illnesses. And I can tell you coming
from myself, I was a person who used to
drink a lot of alcohol before I met
Jesus. And there is a lot of negativity
that comes from that. And it's all
that's used really is that is as
deception from the devil and used to
cover up things in our own lives. So I I
encourage you to stay away from wine.
And those are the examples that the
Bible gives us. Amen. Amen. Not just
wine.
All alcohol. Yeah. Yeah. And you know, I
looked this up in 2024 an estimated
13,000 people died in
alcoholrelated car accidents. Wow. Well,
anyway, thank you for that. That was
that was very informative. Okay, let's
go to Pastor Johnson. In the story of
Job, where God allowed Satan to attack
Job, was it God's will for Satan to
attack Job? This is from Lynette.
Lynette, thank you. This is also an
excellent question because yet again,
the character of God is in question. So,
if you're not familiar with the story of
Job, Job was an upright and wonderful
man. He assued evil and God had a hedge
around him and had blessed him and Satan
made an accusation of God and God
allowed Job to be tested. Let's go to
the word because the first thing I'd
like to do before we even break this
down is let us see what the intent God w
what intent God had for Job. Who was
God? So if you look in Job chapter 1, it
says in verse 9, "And Satan answered the
Lord and said, Doth Job fear God for not
hast not thou made an hedge about him,
and about his house, and about all that
he hath on every side? You have blessed
the work of his hands." This is what God
intended for Job. Let's look at another
example of what God wanted for Job. This
time I'm going to go to the end of Job.
This is Job chapter 42. And I'm going to
read verse 10. And this is after Job had
gone through his trials. It said, "And
the Lord turned the captivity of Job,
set him free, gave him the victory when
Job had prayed for his friends. Also,
the Lord gave Job twice as much as he
had before." That's who God is. And
Satan likes to use the things he does to
give God a bad name. But let us look and
see what's actually happening here.
Because God does allow Job to be tested.
He allows us to be tested. And there's
something major here. But before we get
into it, I would like to introduce a
word into the lexicon, a term, the great
controversy. Anybody heard of that
before? This cosmic battle between good
and evil. It's going on here. So, let's
look. Pastor Lang was talking about
this, how Satan was able to show up at a
meeting that God was having in heaven
before Satan was confined. And the Lord
said unto Satan, Job 1:8, "Have you
considered my servant Job?" You know,
let's go back to seven. The Lord said to
Satan, "Where are you coming from?" And
Satan answered the Lord and said, "From
going to and fro in the earth and
walking up and down in it." Whose earth
is it? It's God's earth. Satan says,
"I'm going up and down in your earth,
God. I'm walking on your earth." Satan,
among other things, is establishing this
false dominion. Oh, come on, Satan. And
then God says, "Have you considered my
servant Job?" And then as we read, Satan
makes an accusation of God. He says,
"The only reason that they serve you is
cuz you bless him." He is accusing God
of being unfair. So now I ask you, who's
on trial here? The character of God is
on trial before the universe. And God
calls as his witness in the court
session of God v. Satan, Job as his
witness. And have we ever considered
that when we go through stuff, God is
calling us as witnesses to testify as to
the goodness of his character? So, was
it God's will that Job be hurt? No. But
was it God's will that Job testify to
the goodness of God? Yes. And the Lord
blessed him. Don't let what Satan does
change our view of who God is. That's
right. Amen. Amen. Amen. That's right.
You may be going through trials right
now, but trust in God. He is there with
you. Whatever you're going through,
remember to pray, talk to him, read the
word. That's where you find your
answers. Thank you, Pastor Ryan. All
right, Pastor John. This is a little
lengthy question, so here goes.
Genesis 1 vers1 says, "In the beginning,
God created the heavens and the earth."
Then goes on to lay out day one to day
six all that God had created, including
his creation of man, and he rested on
the seventh day. 2 Peter 3:8 said, "But
beloved, be not ignorant of this one
thing, that one day is with the Lord as
a thousand years, and a thousand years
as one day."
If one day with the Lord is as a
thousand years, did it take God 6,000
years to create heaven and earth? Then
he rested 1,000 years. This is from
Dawn.
Thank you, Don. Simply put, I could
answer this question in one second. No.
The Bible is not talking about God
saying one day is a thousand years. It
is saying that time does not restrain
God. God is not restrained by time.
Peter said one day with the Lord is as a
thousand years and a thousand years is
as one day. God is not restrained by
time outside of earth. There is no time
factor. God is eternal. God doesn't say,
"Well, you know, like the devil, I have
a short time." There's no time factor
for God. He is eternity. He's from
everlasting. He's to everlasting. He is
the alpha and the omega. There is no
restraint when it comes to God. But in
the earth, God set up a system of time.
Now, what's amazing, people sometimes
say that the world world took 6,000
years to create, and God rested a
thousand years. Well, then all of a
sudden, when did God shift that
6,000year period into a 24-hour day?
Well, he did that from the very
beginning. There was no shift because
there was never a thousand-y year of
creation. Think about it. If one day was
a thousand years, he had 500 years of
light, 500 years of darkness. No plant
would survive in that kind of
environment. But the Bible says in
Genesis 1:14, "Let there be lights in
the firmament of the heavens to divide
the day from the night. Let them be for
signs and seasons for days and for
years." So God established a time system
that is still established today. And the
Bible said at the end of all creation
week, so the Bible says, "So the evening
and the morning were whatever day,
first, second, third, fourth, fifth, and
sixth." And then even after creation,
this time factor continued. Genesis
5:4 speaking about births. The days of
Adam were 800 years and he had sons and
daughters. So all the days of Adam were
930 years and he died. We still have
days and years and hours and weeks
today. So there was no such thing.
That's why the psalmist David ending it
simply this. So teach us to number our
days that we may gain a heart of wisdom.
What are our days? Psalm 90:10. The days
of our lives are 70 years. God
established time through sun, moon,
stars from the very beginning. And it
was not a thousand years of day and a
thousand years of night. It was
consistent time. Amen. All right. Thank
you for that. Amen. And we know there's
a whole religion believes that, you
know, it takes 6,000 years to create the
world. Anyway, let's go on.
Ian, why do we need to pray for
blessings? Mhm. Wouldn't God
automatically want to bless a church, a
ministry, or evangelistic meeting? What
does my individual prayer do? Yeah,
thank you so much again for your
question. This is kind of interesting
because you said something earlier that
I have in my notes and you said
something earlier that I have in my
notes. So, it's kind of tying it all
together. But, of course, God wants to
bless us all the time. But
unfortunately, we have uh a theme out
there called the great controversy
between God and Satan. So, we do have an
enemy that is out there that seeks to do
us harm. Revelation 12:12 tells us that
the devil has come down to you having
great wrath because he knows that he has
a short time. So, if and also if we
receive blessings upon blessings all day
every day, really what need would we
have for a savior? So, we can see though
in Ephesians chapter 6, we're told, "For
we do not wrestle against flesh and
blood, but against principalities,
against powers, against the rulers of
the darkness of this age, against
spiritual hosts of wickedness in
heavenly places." And then we're also
told that we need to take up the whole
armor of God. We need to girdge your
waist with truth to have put on the
breastplate of righteousness. Shod your
feet with the preparation of the gospel
of peace taking the shield of faith
taking the helmet of salvation and the
sword of the spirit which is the word of
God. And then in verse 18 praying always
with all prayer and supplication in the
spirit. So we need to be in a state of
prayer to protect ourselves and to ask
God to bless us from the evil one. And
the first part of your question though
was why do we need to pray for
blessings? Well, for one, that's what
Jesus did. Amen. Uh and he is our
example. And if he is our example, then
we should be doing the same exact thing
that Jesus did. You can read all
throughout the Bible in many places
where Jesus uh took time to go off and
spend time in prayer and one-on-one time
with God. And then we're also told
though in in John chapter 17 where Jesus
not only prays for himself, he prays for
his disciples and he prays for all the
believers. Now that sounds a little bit
like praying for your church, praying
for your ministry and praying for
evangelism, does it not? Now the last
part to your question was what does my
individual prayer do for me? And this is
so key. Your individual prayer gives you
an opportunity to speak from the to God
the creator of the universe. uh
reference Nehemiah 9:6 and Acts
4:24. Prayer of faith heals the sick.
James 5:15. Prayer gives you peace.
Philippians 4:es 6 and 7. Prayer gives
you access to wisdom that is beyond your
capacity. James 1 uh verse 5. Prayer
also gives relational healing. James 5
and:e 16. Prayer releases you from the
bondage of sin and addiction. Acts 12:es
5-7. And prayer saves. Amen. Hebrews
chapter 7 verse 25. And doesn't just
save you but saves those who you are
praying for. In closing, I want to say
this. One of the reasons why I am here
is because of prayer. Come on. My wife
had prayed for me for 11 years until I
finally gave my heart over to God. And
there is a prayer right now that echoes
through all eternity that was said by
Jesus in Luke 23 and:34 which says Jesus
then says, "Father, forgive them for
they know not what they do." Amen. That
is a prayer that has echoed throughout
all eternity. So don't ever think that
there is no reason to pray or to ask for
God's blessings upon you. Amen. Amen.
Well said. I can't add to that. Amen.
Thank you, Ryan. Not Ryan. Thank you,
Ian. You're welcome. I'm going on to
Ryan right now.
Okay, Pastor Johnson, here's your
question. Why does the book Song of
Songs, which is a Song of Solomon, exist
in the Bible? What is its purpose? How
come no one talks about it? This is from
Anthony in Ohio. Hi, Anthony. This is a
great question, too. Um, this book, The
Song of Solomon, it has a love language
in it. We're going to look at it
briefly, but the first thing to
understand is that this is written and
it is an eastern culture. And sometimes
when we read this with our western eyes,
it can be hard to see what's going on
here. So, let's break it down. Um, it is
called Shir Hasharim and that the direct
translation is Song of Songs and it is
in the form of a poem, but in the
translation, you know, we don't really
feel the exact same rhythm and stuff as
originally was in there. It is credited
to Solomon most of the content here. So
one of the first answers to your
question is this is content from the
king and so it is very very important
especially it was in Jewish culture.
What else? It is a conversation between
the king and his bride. Oh look at that.
And if you read through there you will
see this back and forth and it changes
personage of who was talking and stuff
like that. Let's see what else can we
find. The bride is a simple sulamite
woman. Some believe that that is also um
synonymous with being a shunomite girl.
And it discusses ideal Eastern love. So
that's what we have going on here. But
when you read the scripture, I was
taught always look for the gospel. Yes.
In the story. Yes. Let's see if we can
find the gospel in here. So I'm going to
go to Song of Solomon's right after
Ecclesiastes. And we're right here in
chapter one. Let's begin reading. I'm
going to read starting in verse six.
Here's the woman speaking. Listen now.
Look not upon me because I am black.
Because the son hath looked upon me. My
mother's children were angry with me.
They have made me the keeper of the
vineyards. Now, if you clutched your
pearls at that, it's okay. Don't Let's
just break this down. Nothing wrong with
being black. Amen. In fact, if you look
at the original word there, the
translation in this context is I am
tanned. Now, usually when this word is
used, it is used positively. But here,
this young woman is ashamed of being
tanned. How do we know she meant tanned
and not referring to her race? Because
it says, "I am black because the sun sun
hath looked upon me." Well, why does
this matter? Because she's admitting
she's a working girl. She's out there in
the vineyards working our heart and the
sun is beating down and you can tell
looking at her exactly where her station
as it were in life was. I'm not worthy
because I've just a girl who works in
the fields. Now look what the king says
in verse 10. Thy cheeks are comely with
rolls rows of jewels. Come on king. Thy
neck with chains of gold. Do you see the
gospel? Ah, here is the woman feeling
unworthy.
Here is the king saying, "I love you
anyhow." Yes. That is the primary
message of the Song of Songs.
Amen. Thank you for that. He has loved
us with an everlasting love. Praise God.
What we're going to do is take a short
break and we will be right back.
If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at
bibleqa3abn.tv. That's
bibleqa3abn.tv. You may also text your
questions to 6182283975.
That's
618-228-3975. Be sure to include your
name and where you live and then watch
through Bible Q&A for answers from God's
word.
Welcome back. I hope you've enjoyed and
learned a lot from this program. I know
I have. Well, we have a few closing
thoughts from our wonderful
distinguished panelists. Pastor Johnson,
what is your closing thought? You know,
I would like to share with you something
that Pastor Lomchang was just telling
me. He was saying that the spirit of
prophecy states that when Christ went
into the wilderness, it was there that
he encountered all of the temptations
and the things that we would encounter.
And so consider that he is led into the
wilderness to show us that we can have
victory over sin, tempted in every way,
victorious in every way. Yes. Amen.
Amen. We can and we will once we trust
in Jesus. Thank you, Ian. Yeah. I just
want to say that to the person who sent
the question about, you know, what does
my prayer do for me? Never think that
your prayers don't do anything for you
because the Bible even says in James
5:16, the effective and fervent prayer
of a righteous man avails much. Amen.
Thank you. And simply put, number your
days. You don't have a whole lot. You
never know when your days will close,
but trust the Lord and your days will be
a time when you can prepare for
eternity. God has given you that time.
Use it wisely. Amen. Wow. Thank you so
much all three of you. I love this
program. I'm going to leave a scripture
with you. Psalm 119:11. Your word I have
hidden in my heart that I might not sin
against you. Amen. Continue to trust
Jesus. He has a future and a hope for
you. God bless you. Amen.
[Music]